good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-956 l4 by 3 by 3
meters at the end of hallway 99 at site
17 the subject is to be provided the
following 1.5 kilograms of fresh liver
daily for consumption clean drinking
water and plentiful quantities and clean
bedding futon and blankets to be
exchanged by the subject and laundered
weekly small luxury items plum wine
reading materials etc may be provided as
an occasional reward for good behavior
as part of psychological conditioning
direct human contact with scp-956
forbidden due to scp-956 own when the
hermetically sealed door is opened
delivery of food and other items will be
carried out by an automated robotic
assistant should containment fail SCP
9:53 can be theoretically terminated by
gun fire however due to its nature
recognizing SCP 9:53 may be difficult
because of the inadequacy of purely
physical containment procedures to
control SCP 9:53 psychological
containment is also necessary for this
reason the approach to scp-956 hound
breed scp-956 treem phobia of
domesticated canines and will not pass
within
ten meters of one especially when
canines are barking or alerted SCP 950
armed at all times any transport must be
done under the supervision of at least
six armed personnel it's preferred
killing method is a barehanded strike to
the abdomen penetrating the abdominal
cavity and removing the liver which it
will later consume if given time however
it will choose to linger over its kill
torturing its victim as it seems to
enjoy the infliction of pain upon
another sentient being description
scp-956 approximately eight kilograms in
weight with a spine that splits around
the 26 vertebrae into nine separate
tails subject displays polymorphic
properties however allowing it to take
the form of various other objects and
beings most commonly an attractive
Korean female subject will display some
vulpine aspect ears tail paws eyes for
voice mannerisms in all its alternate
forms disconcert to identify the subject
should it attempt disguise although
scp-956 and other methods in addition to
its polymorphic abilities scp-956 onic
abilities namely suggestion and
telepathy
although insufficient to fool an outside
observer and entranced subject can be
convinced of a variety of false facts
including the nature of scp-956 Ria's
used this in the past to among other
things
deceive police officers investigating
reports of loud screams from hotel room
convinced a mother to roast and eat her
own child carry out
upon agent Ramses fiance in full view of
said agent and succeed in the systematic
murder of 27 attendees of youth conv
addendum one prior history SCP 950
times with the first encounter having
taken place in Busan Korea shortly after
the Second World War to date scp-956
times resulting in the deaths of SCP
agents during various incidents after
its latest escape as CP 953 was not
heard of for years until suddenly
resurfacing in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
on June 2000 at EF Con 20 which it had
been attending in the guise of a furry
enthusiast before being captured SCP 952
of convention staff and attendees more
than during any other single incident to
date the mutilated bodies were found in
various places throughout the hotel
including inside a mattress hanging from
a shower curtain and served as the main
course and a hotel banquet the surviving
attendees were administered class-a
amnesiacs and released from foundation
custody foundation personnel is signed
to capture SCP 950
noted that the subject appeared listless
and apathetic and did not resist capture
no further casualties have resulted from
SCP nine 53 from that date addendum to
special emergency order as
misidentification of her species tends
to violently agitated CP 953 all
personnel are to be hereby ordered to
refer to her as kamijo and not gitsune a
personnel asking what the differences
are to be reminded of the difference
between a Cherokee Indian and a new
deli Indian oh [ __ ] addendum 3 personnel
staffing revision following the
unfortunate and completely preventable
death of agent Gallagher and a personnel
found to have current or prior ties to
the furry or otaku communities are to be
immediately reassigned to other projects
el5 addendum for folkloric control
procedures as a reminder staff assigned
to scp-956 truck shion's for interacting
with the subject no matter how odd or
arbitrary they may seem keep in mind too
that people of Asia interacted with
these beings for centuries before we
came on to the scene what we think of as
fairy tales were their version of
special containment procedures held five
9:53 interview a interview with capture
team following initial capture of
scp-956
hospital protocol all information on oh
five points prior identity has been
removed
interviewer assistant director
henceforth referred to as interviewer
forward this interview took place on two
days after the capture of scp-956 3
appendix nine 53v
prior incidents casualties resulting
from agent was the only survivor of the
incident during which he accomplished
the task of capturing a CP 953 alive the
following is a transcript of the
after-action debriefing that took place
following scp-956
huh this transcript was digitized under
the foundation modernization directive
confirmation of file integrity confirmed
by tech operator some formatting
terminology and compatibility
discrepancies with modern interview logs
may exist due to the restructuring of
where possible current events have been
appended begin log alright let's begin
please state your name rank and registry
number for the record each death squad
Easter division thanks can you tell me
what you remember about the events on
and around alright where do you want me
to start how about the beginning where
were you when you got your orders
thank you for clearing that up can you
tell me what happened when you arrived
on site yeah no problem we got on site
and we went to the morgue took a minute
to look at the bodies
I used the cover story of a reporter
investigating the crimes I told them
agent one and agent two were my
photographer and assistant
turns out they were thinking it was a
wild animal based on the nature of the
wounds and eyewitnesses accounts it was
an eyewitness yeah
little old lady went out into the rice
fields to take a piss and solid eating
her cow she was more mad than scared
actually kept complaining about where
she was gonna get another cow in this
day and age but the times being as tough
as they were she got a good look at it
though described it as looking back hey
take that's where the problem started
can you explain remember how agent one
and agent - were both but I was
the thing is both our cultures have
stories of these kinds of monsters in it
but it's different for these folklore
their stories tend to romanticize you
get stories of monsters falling in love
with humans and things a lot hell they
even joked about trying to score life
out of this not in the stories my
grandma told though that sadistic old
[ __ ] loved scaring me and she's we saw
this girl sitting under a waterfall
combing her hair not naked
she had this thin robe on beautiful girl
too but we knew it had to be her because
of her feet she was trying to hide them
but she wasn't doing it right agent one
an agent too smart even I thought we had
the edge on God we were stupid please
explain she knew we were after her she
knew we knew what she was she was she
was it's like a spider she was pulling
us into a web pretended to let her guard
down just enough so that we would feel
smug and our overconfidence I should
have I don't know I should have tried
something I should have done this
something do you need a moment no no
I'll go on she told us that she had a
cottage nearby offered to service dinner
introduce us to the others why God why
did I agree agent one and agent two
thought we should go with her said there
was a chance that there might be others
she was lying she knew there was no one
else she knew that we never pass up the
chance to capture multiple out-of-place
artifacts she took us to this cottage
pretty little place you know old and
rustic but really homey Lukas inside
served us dinner she was perfect well
that agent won't call it a perfect wife
in your kind sweet respectful served us
I remember it was rice and pickled
turnips and some kind of some kind of
meat I thought it was pork beef
it was delicious though went to bed
feeling sleepy and tired woke up and saw
that agent one wasn't there
figured he'd gone to take a piss or
something so that is how did it go for
one myself went behind the bush and saw
well she was there with agent one they
were I mean please go on do you mind if
I say this part off the record it's not
very as you wish
thank you what did you see after that
she she bit it off please elaborate she
just bit it off all of it
and then she spat it out and showed it
to him just so that he could see it
happening agent one just he couldn't
believe it at first then he was trying
to scream but she corn is thrown out
with her teeth and she made her hand
like this stabbed it into his belly
haegeum was gurgling and trying to push
her off he was bleeding all over the
place but she just pushed into the
ground and started working her fingers
in his belly he reached in deep pulled
something must have been his liver it
was the right shape and color just
pulled it out like she was gunning a
fish that's all it at home swallowed it
Oh like a snake just one gulp like that
then she started peeling his skin off
like an orange or something good I
didn't stop to watch I ran back to the
room and shook it to awake told him we
needed to get going grab your gun he
didn't I went for our weapons grabbed my
45 and then agent one walked in asked
him what was wrong so I shot him he shot
him I saw him die he was dead she killed
him it had to be her are you sure
perhaps you were mistaken she tore his
guts out and ate them he was dead and
his eyes were glowing yellow what the
hell kind of human being has glowing
yellow eyes I see please proceed
agent to grab this gun and pointed it at
me started yelling at me to put the gun
down I was yelling at him to look at her
but he was screaming that he was gonna
shoot me in the head because I was a
dirty and he always knew I was one and
now I just proved it that's when the
[ __ ] grabbed him from behind and the
gun went off this is when you were
injured yeah he shot me in the arm
fleshy part of her shoulder I fell down
screaming and God it hurts so bad
loud cackling laughs oh god if I thought
my grandma's was scary this [ __ ] she
was if the devil Worth lady that's what
he'd sound like Bradford crawled into
the living room where we'd had dinner
earlier that night and tried to slam the
door shut
rice-paper scream I'm not gonna help but
I just I needed something between us
kill them and laid him out where the
dining table had been his eyes were wide
open and his skin was flayed open like a
butcher's there were the Bulls the ones
we've been eating out of the meat it
wasn't beef or pork it it was him and
the rice
and maggots crawling in his flesh he'd
have had to been dead for days but how
we'd seen him at the base of the
mountain just yesterday I threw up there
were some of them were still alive
crawling in my vomit and I just do you
need a break no no no I can I can do
this I was deep in the fairy tale I just
needed to complete it I didn't have
anything it wasn't much of a punji stick
but it got her straight through the gut
let's let her down a bit
dragging myself across the river good
sweat if my head on the rocks went
downstream at least half a mile through
the rapids she didn't even try to follow
me down river must have gone around
because splitter had to be fire the
third was always fine I got the devant
about the time the Sun came up broke a
window and went to the back there was a
flamethrower sorry different predictor
therefore sterilization if needed so I
grabbed it flicked on the sparker and
managed to get it around just as she
came out of the tree line and that was
when the retrieval team found you with
the other place artifact
yeah and they took her away and helped
me to a hospital
I had a raging infection for days not
surprising I guess one last thing you've
been on the record as opposing now to
place artifacts termination given your
personal experiences I'm really not sure
why you'd want something as dangerous as
this to live can you please elaborate
I'm not sure I understand are you saying
that you sympathize with her sympathize
I don't know no I can't say that I do
she killed me just as soon as look at me
just out of spite because she is
spiteful she'd kill me just to watch me
die but what she's trying to do if she
doesn't she
he will also on record as opposing her
terms of confinement because it's
dangerous
like I said she's spiteful every little
slight in her eyes saves up and the only
way she knows how to repay an insult is
death
Jeanne her to the wall like an animal
when she gets out and she well get out
she is gonna kill everyone who had the
slightest thing to do with it she won't
settle for anything else he will also
paid her several visits in a holding
cell yes I have what do you talk about
agent you had a harrowing traumatic
experience based around this individual
in order to survive you had to be in
your own words get into her head you
realize how she takes one might even say
that there was some times you spent as a
captive during the hump in the woods I
don't know what you're getting at have
you ever heard of Stockholm Syndrome yes
is it possible that no no no just no
thank you very much for your time
agent end log
closing statement agent is to be
transferred to site 51 for psychological
analysis and debriefing the out of place
artifact in question is to be remanded
to secure confinement protocols as
indicated in document 953 Alif on a side
note I am appalled by the level of
superstition expressed by agent
throughout the course of this interview
I am recommending that his suggestions
regarding containment be disregarded for
a more scientific approach we're not
korean fishwives here I'm sure we can
think of something more effective than
dogs and needles assistant director
addendum
as of scp-956
time resulting in the deaths of those
operatives most closely involved in
their confinement ADA was approved to
return to active duty on and continues
to serve with the restructure of mobile
task force theta 3 you know and of all
the things that I thought I would
include in an SCP lecture if Khan never
entered my head anyway thank you all for
listening if indeed you still are and I
hope everyone's doing well
I know these are really tough times
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to the Morrigan mr. blew up geum's Sabha
arbiter sue it's not a spoon
Darius Tom art Thomas Justin day and
jayvo Jack Cory Barker Chloe Harlan
Samurai corgis and Nathan if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Vulcan thank you
you